hey youtubers it's Charlie so you guys
requested a black order video for
infinity war because they cast a new
character so I'll explain the whole team
what their powers and abilities are and
what they're going to change for the
movie there's a new round of the Marvel
giveaway for those new action figures
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so we're going to talk about the black
order if you've never read them in the
comics they were part of Jonathan
Hickman tour of duty that went all the
way from 2013 through Secret Wars so all
credit to Jonathan Hickman but the black
order is basically like fan OSes group
of lieutenants that he uses leading up
into the big infinity crossover event so
before Secret Wars what was happening is
that Thanos was traveling all over the
galaxy tracking down the last remaining
children that he had killing them off
and then he found there was one more
called Thane and he was on earth
somewhere but he didn't know where he
was
so Thanos sends these mysterious new
lieutenants that you're seeing for the
first time they were created in 2013 so
it wasn't like they appeared before this
and this is very comic book stuff I'll
explain how the movies have already
changed this a little bit you have
actually met some of Santos's Black
Order in the movies but one of them has
already been killed off and to have
bailed on him Kimora I mean your
challenge she was apprehended by the
Nova the other one here with nothing to
show for it your sources say that she
meant to betray us the whole time I got
tired I think
so the original lineup is Proxima
midnight black dwarf Corvus glaive
evany mah in supergiant they're sent to
earth to find Bannos his son as well as
the location of all the infinity gems
the Illuminati have been hiding them so
all over the earth simultaneously you
just see them appear like holy crap
is going down what is happening here
black dwarf goes to Wakanda to try and
take Black Panther down black panther
being the badass seediest
defeats his army Proxima midnight is
able to get the information about the
infinity gems from Namor who sort of
flipping sides this is also the lead up
to the creation of the Cabal - so the
Illuminati is sort of already a morally
grey collection of the most powerful
people on earth who make decisions that
aren't necessarily the nicest but are in
the interest of prolonging the human
species but because this is the lead-up
to secret Wars and all the earth from
other universes are slowly colliding
with each other earth they have to find
a way to save reality in name war feels
like the Illuminati are not up to the
task to make the hard call so he goes to
Thanos and all these other really evil
people to form their own version of the
Illuminati who will do what it takes to
survive one of the other members of the
Black Order
evany mah is the person who goes to see
Doctor Strange and get the actual
location of Venice's son because a lot
of them are sent on wild goose chases
thinking the ease that Professor X's
school sort of the last piece of
Santos's dark version of the Avengers
are the outriders think of it as like a
xenomorph from the alien series that
were slightly more intelligent in
assassins so in addition to his own
version of The Avengers he also has like
this race of xenomorphs that he sends
after targets if he needs something done
really quickly slowly over time the
roster changes members are killed or
kicked out by Thanos Black Swan joins so
the roster right now is a little
different than they used to be and
obviously Marvel has gone through a
version of its rebirth because at the
end of that arc Stannis gets trapped in
living death but then because of all the
incursions he's freed he winds up being
killed by Doctor Doom with the power of
the beyonders during secret Ward's which
was
kind of disappointing because of this
huge buildup for Thanos during Secret
Wars and then dr. doom takes them out
like a boss but the thing is to bring it
back around to the movies what they're
talking about is that Thanos will only
have about three right-hand people in
the movie so we might see a couple
members of the Black Order but it won't
be the entire roster and the reason
people are going crazy about this is
because the motion capture actor that
did Kong during Skull Island
said that he's doing fantasies
right-hand man during infinity war
meaning he's going to be a male motion
capture member of the Black Order so
they're only a couple of choices and
they've already done the other he's kind
of like the ebony ma of the group he was
killed by Ronin during guardians of the
galaxy so odds are on Corvus glaive or
black dwarf so I feel like of those two
Corvus glaive is a little bit more
likely to be motion capture just because
of the way his powers work seriously
Corvus glaive can reconstitute himself
from a single atom as long as his blade
is intact
he gets one shot in here by Hyperion one
of the most powerful people in the
Marvel Universe and completely comes
back just because the blade is still
intact so imagine someone like Captain
Marvel takes him down during infinity
war and he just completely comes back
that would be the most badass visual
effects sequence so of course you'd have
to do a bunch of motion capture black
dwarf is really just like another
version of the thing but the way his
powers work so it's not that spectacular
he's just really strong he has super
strong skin that's about it his real
power is in his blade here it gives him
a measure of immortality so as long as
the blade is whole he is functionally
immortal but he also has super speed
super strength super durability which is
kind of true of all the fantasies
lieutenants like all of them have a
measure of super strength because
they're all super jacked up if you want
to take it a step further he technically
is Santos's master strategist so if this
motion capture actor is being true to
form in saying he's going to be
fantasies right-hand man not just one of
his hired thugs but all signs point to
Corvus glaive but they could make some
minor changes for the movies my favorite
member is probably Proxima midnight
she's actually the husband of Corvus
glaive but the spear that she wields
that was crafted for her by Thanos
himself is a combination of a star
supernovae in a black hole all at once
so when she throws it at someone she has
the ability to control its density is
also laced in a lethal toxin that is
capable of taking the whole town that's
sort of a common theme with the Black
Order is that they're all powerful
enough to take on the most powerful
Avengers as any mods power is persuasion
so he's able to get information out of
someone as powerful as Doctor Strange
you think he'd be impervious to those
types of attacks supergiant powers are
somewhat similar
she has direct mind-control abilities
more traditional mind-control psychic
possession she can possess a bunch of
people at the same time it's not just a
one on one thing and she can do it
across great distance so the other
members of the black orders that we've
already seen in the movies are actually
Gamora
and nebula those were his lieutenants
that were working for him keeping an eye
on Ronan while he was searching for the
Infinity gem had they not gone rogue
they would be doing the exact same thing
for Thanos during Infinity Ward they
would be going around trying to grab the
gems
so during guardians of the galaxy - even
though there's not going to be any fan
OHS in the movie you'll still get some
of that storyline like you see nebula
here captive of the sovereigns this race
of genetically perfect people that the
guardians are trying to work a job for
she looks like she is at a kicked
out of her and she is on the run so
Thanos is probably displeased with her
in her failure during the first Guardian
film so that probably leads her to this
moment here so if you want to read a
really cool story with the Black Order
you can start with New Avengers vol 1
everything dies read all the way through
vol 2 infinity then time runs out then
Secret Wars so they'll be borrowing a
lot of inspiration from the New Avengers
comic from the Jonathan Hickman
characters but as with all things the
movie is doing more of the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline so obviously it's
going to be changing a lot of things
from that infinity comic book storyline
so New Avengers infinity and the
Infinity Gauntlet are two completely
different stories speaking of other
characters working with Bannos a lot of
people are asking about pizza troll who
got tied up during the infinity watch
Infinity Gauntlet storyline in the
comics the thing about that is that
Peter Dinklage typically doesn't play
characters that are known for their
physicality like he played Bulevar
traffic during x-men Days of Future past
he's not somebody who's small of stature
he's just like a character who's really
big for this story so what I'm expecting
is the Peter Dinklage is playing a
really important character but not
someone who is really small in the
comics but a lot of people are like is
he going to play The Watcher are we
actually going to get the watcher during
infinity war I think because of
Fantastic Four rights and the Fox stuff
that they won't be able to do The
Watcher he'll be an earth-based
character he's not going to be motion
capture or anything like that
he'll just be somebody who's very
important he typically plays maligned
characters with really questionable
morality his version of Tyrion on Game
of Thrones is more of a straight-up
protagonist he's less morally great than
a lot of the other characters that he's
played but since he's done Tyrion a lot
of the roles that he's gone after had
had nothing to do with their size so
it's still totally possible that he's
playing pit patrol but I think it's
really low on the list of likelihood I
think odds are he's playing a new
character but if we get more information
I'll do more videos about it there's
still a lot of mysteries about what's
going on with infinity war the black
order is just like the latest greatest
surprise because they are bad as I
cannot wait to see what they do with
them in the movies but let me know in
the comments who is your favorite member
of the Black Order in the only ones that
I think that they probably won't do will
be like super Giants because she already
looks kind of like Gamora and if you
look at Proxima midnight here who does
that remind you of that looks an awful
lot like hella from Thor Ragnarok so
there's going to be a lot of crossover
with the phase 3 movies that are coming
up so I'll be doing a guardians of the
galaxy video later today about
post-credit scenes where I'll talk about
how I think some of those characters
might cross over to Thanos his story
life especially hella she is way too big
to die at the end of thor ragnarok way
too cool of a villain so what's going to
happen is is later today I'll post that
Guardians video there's a new Wonder
Woman trailer so if you're not already
be sure to subscribe to get all that
stuff there's the giveaway that's going
on now to announce the winner when I
post that Guardians video so I'll try to
get that out as fast as possible while
you wait for that click here for that
door Ragnarok preview and click here to
learn all about Domino and Deadpool -
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video